>> WELCOME BACK.
GROUP WOMEN IN GIRLS FEELING FO
THEIR SAFETY AS THE TALIBAN
TAKES CONTROL.
THERE ARE REPORTS THAT THE
DELAVAN IS ALREADY FORCING YOUN
GIRLS TO MARRY THEIR FIGHTERS.
WHILE THOSE CONCERNS ARE GROWING
, PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE
SUPPORTS DEFENDING HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO SPEAK OU
FOR THE BASIC RIGHTS OF THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE, OF WOMEN IN GIRLS
, JUST AS WE SPEAK OUT ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
I HAVE BEEN CLEAR, HUMAN RIGHTS
MUST BE THE CENTER OF OUR
FOREIGN POLICY, NOT THE
PERIPHERY.
BUT THE WAY TO DO IT IS NOT
THROUGH ENDLESS MILITARY
DEPLOYMENTS.
>> THAT'S FINE, BUT WHAT HAPPEN
TO THE WOMEN IN GIRLS NOW WHO
ARE FEARING FOR THEIR LIVES.
>> IN RECORD TIME.
THE PROBLEM WITH PUTTING A
STATEMENT OUT THERE OR HAVING
PEOPLE TALK AROUND THE ISSUE AN
IN THE LAST SEGMENT, WE'VE SEEN
THE PICTURES NOW, AND THERE IS
NOT MULTIPLE WAYS TO INTERPRET
THAT.
IT WERE IN THE STREETS, HORROR
IN THE AIRPORTS.
OUR EMBASSY HAS BEEN CLEARED,
OUR FLAGS ARE COMING HOME, AND
THAT HAS REAL AND PRACTICAL
MEANING.
WE ARE NOT THERE ANYMORE TO
PROTECT THEM.
I THINK THERE IS THIS
INTERESTING DICHOTOMY GOING ON,
BUT HE ALSO GOT IT RIGHT ON THI
VERY JUST A LITTLE WHILE AGO,
JASON CROW WHO IS A CONGRESSMAN
IN A VETERAN HAD A BILL PUTTING
FORWARD TO FAST-TRACK THESE
APPLICATIONS FOR AFGHANS IN
LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT WE
DECIDED WE ARE GOING TO COME
HOME.
IT WAS HUGELY POPULAR ONLY 16
CONGRESSPEOPLE VOTED AGAINST IT.
THOSE OTHER KINDS OF ACTIONS
THAT PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING
THAT WE HAVE SENT THEIR NEED TO
BE TAKEN IN WE NEED ANSWERS IN
ACCOUNTABILITY CHAIN OF HOW THI
ENDED UP IN THIS WAY BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO SUFFER THE MOST FROM A
HASTY WITHDRAWAL.
>> IS IT JUST LIP SERVICE.
WE HEARD THE SAME THING FROM
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS WHEN SHE
VISITED THE BORDER IN SHE TALKE
ABOUT AN INITIATIVE THAT SHE HA
HELPING WOMEN IN GIRLS.
BUT STILL REALLY NOT A ROOT
CAUSE, YOU CAN TALK ABOUT IT YO
CAN SEND THOUGHTS IN PRAYERS,
BUT WHAT DOES THAT REALLY DO.
>> IN HER CASE, LET ME READ YOU
WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT THE WOMEN.
SHE SAID NOTHING.
THERE IS NOTHING TO READ GRADE
SHE'S SKIPPED OVER THE FACT THA
WOMEN WILL GO BACK TO THE BACK
OF THE HOUSE TO RAISE THE KIDS.
WHEN THEY SAY THEY CAN GO TO TH
SCHOOL, WHAT WILL THEY DO.
I BRING BACK TO THIS COMMENT
THAT IS WIDELY CIRCULATED,
RICHARD OBERG SAID THIS WHEN HE
SAID TO THIS HE SAID YOU GOT TO
PUT MORE TIME IN EFFORT.
WHAT ABOUT THE WOMEN, YOU CAN'T
LET A BULL OUT OF AFGHANISTAN I
2008 BIDEN REPLIED WITH A
HISTORY LESSON HE SAID, WHAT HE
SAID ABOUT THE AMERICAN
APPLICATION IN AFGHANISTAN LIKE
THE GIRLS IN THE KABUL SCHOOL,
HE REPLAYED F THEM, WE DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT, WITH
DIDN'T IN VIETNAM AND WE HAVE.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK HE FEELS NOW
?
>> I DON'T KNOW, HE SAYING THAT
FIGHTING MISOGYNY IN FIGHTING
FOR WOMEN THAT IS THE HALLMARK
OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
SHOULD HE GET A PASS?
I THINK THAT NANCY PELOSI IS
GOING TO GIVE HIM A PASS SINCE
SHE SPEAKER THE HOUSE IN SHE
SAID YESTERDAY BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT SAID ANYTHING THAT TH
PRESIDENT IS TO BE COMMENDED FO
THE CLARITY OF HIS STATEMENT
REGARDING AFGHANISTAN AND IT
SAYS WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
REPORTS.
THE SPOKESMAN OF THE PENTAGON I
ACTUALLY THINK THE WAY THAT HE
ANSWERED THE AFGHAN REPORTER WA
A LOT MORE EMPATHY IN CARE IN
CONCERN IN A LITTLE MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF HOW AMERICANS
FEEL.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A LOT MORE
HEARTFELT FOR THE TONE IN TENOR
OF THE PRESIDENCY.
>> THIS IS REAL LIFE IN REAL
DEATH, AND I THINK SHE'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT FOR IT I DON'T
THINK THE PRESIDENT TOUCHED ON
THAT ENOUGH.
SOMETIMES, THESE PLATITUDES ARE
BECAUSE WHO IS GOING TO DOCUMEN
THE LIVES IN MURDERS OF THE
WOMEN ARE LEFT BEHIND AND
ESSENTIALLY SUBJUGATED.
>> AND HOW CAN WE BE EXPLOITING
OUR VALUES WHEN WE CONSIDER IN
OUR OWN COUNTRY THAT OUR VALUES
ARE OPPRESSIVE.
WE ARE TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
WILL THE SQUAD CONVENTION OR
CONDEMN THIS CULTURAL RESURGENCE
?
WE HAVE READ IT.
WE'VE READ HARD LESSONS TO
DEFEND THE ROLE OF WOMEN IN
RADICAL ISLAM, SO IT'S GOING TO
BE HARD TO SEE THESE PEOPLE SAY
WELCOME WHAT WE NEED MORE
AMERICAN VALUES OVER THERE.
GOOD LUCK.
>> THEY NEED MORE HISTORY
LESSONS BECAUS